SIDE OF THE STORYY H' THE
SSILDREN AND TW.
IN AN RVIE BY HI
RNON
THE  CER.O BLAMED THEAYED OE CL
NO WAY TEAK  THAT
HWAIT FOR THE RIGHT
KEYS, HE SCNN HAS REACHED OU
ICN THE HO
BU ARREDONDO'SATTORNEY, THE CHI
TIME.
JANE IS ONHE REPORTERS FOR THENN
INR CAPATY THIINO  HHIIE
EKS LATER,
NG
OM. BE
ANO,OW?
ANTHI  FN YOUROW
THAT SO MAVE HAD IN
TERMS OF WHAT HE THE I
IF IT WA'TWAS R D TO B
THOUGHT G -- O LEAST HE  U OUR
THE INCIDENTOMNDR
TIFIEDSE
COMMANDERD NEVER
GAVE AN ORDER FOR AN
SIN
OM
ME
E HES F INEXT ASWHW EMENT MORE O
IS - CNI, VI
HIS HAS BECOME A
BEING SCNI>>S ATTITU ITERMS OF
INOM
SCAPEGOATED?S LE
AT WAS TATION HE EOPLE
EXAI
CLEAR THAT  TRYING TO P AT  ELN
POY EN TT RESPONDED.OT
BUT HE IS ALSO A
COMMUNITY.
RE.
1S OFHIS CARE A PNEE VITH
ERY CL'T SPOKEN OUT OF RESPEILAT
T R WHAT NEEDED FOR WH
HEHO WASCCURAT LE
SED
ENFORCEMENT AUTHIE
>> IT'S T YOUR JOB TDE
KNOW YOU'RRTER
BRINGING THE INFORMATION.I JUST
TERMS OF THE POLICE RESPONSE IN
THMEENTENC THINGS HE SPOKE ABOU
>>IG'SO
NT ON TH
ALD D DECIDE FOR THEMSEL YOU
STORCED DOORS
HE'S TALKING ABOUT, HE IS
TELLING USINK THIS
KE A NEW DAI
E
TRYINGE CAN GET
INSIDE AND SEE IF LARCEMENOULD N
HE CED DOOR, FOUND THAKETHAT
PRLE DOORS  OF
SORT OF THEPOWE ACHOOTER
INCIDENTS.E
SUALLY STUDE
AND TEACHERS, AND  DIFFICULT
FOOPE,Y
BROR GET INSE. GMALEINSIDE CLASS
N GETSPPED AOMES VERY DIFFICULT
E,BREAK WN AS PEOPLE
HA SUGSTTHE SHOOTEEN
HE THEN ASKED FO OEXTRICATIOOLOG
EVERYONE TO READ THI
INFORMATION, TO GIVE THA
CONTEXT.
AND ALSO TALLYIN
NOTIORICADE
VECT